you may have heard the argument that
immigrants are stealing American jobs
from native-born citizens they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists and some I assume are
good people this is a crude
simplification that ignores the reality
and the complexity of immigration and
how it impacts the American economy now
the reality is that immigration has a
multi-faceted impact while it is true
that some immigrants May compete with
some native born workers for some jobs
they also create new jobs they're
spending in the economy creates massive
economic growth and in fact research has
shown that immigration has a positive
overall impact on the economy